ستوديو دكتور سعد جبار الخبير في القانون
الدولي دكتور لماذا اللجوء الى محكمه
الجنايات الدوليه وهي همم محكمه تكميليه
لان اسرائيل رفضت بتحقيق في هذا الموضوع
واعلنت واكدت انه لا توجد مبررات لفتح
تحقيق الجنائي
كذلك ان اسرائيل معروفه انها حتى لو اجر
تحقيق لن يكون تحقيقا نزيهم وهذا بالرجوع
الى الثوابك في هذه المجال عندما تفتح
السلطه الاسرائيليه تحقيق فانه لا يؤدي
الى نتيجه بالنسبه اذا كان الطرف المعني
هو الطرف الاسرائيلي نعم طيب همم سمعنا
بعض الضيوف او بعد عفوا المشاركين في هذا
المؤتمر الصحفي يتحدثون على تحقيق الذي
همم
التحقيقات
وعلاقته بهذه القضيه المعوضه امام المحكمه
الجنايات المطالبه بتحقيق بفتح تحقيق
الجريمه همم هل من تاثير لهذا تحقيق على
على يعني هذه الشكوى المقدمه قبل المحكمه
الجنيه الدوليه هو منذ الناحيه الظاهريه
ان فتح تحقيق مكه الاغبياء يخدموا
الاسرائيليين لانه هناك محاوله لاستلام
الملف من محكمه الجنايه الدوليه وبالتالي
يخدم اسرائيلي بطريقه غير مباشره لكن
الحقيقه انا بحكي هذا يؤثر في المحكمه في
مجرى التحقيق والمحاكمه ان اكد المدد الى
اين اكاد المحكمه اقتصاها لماذا لان
المحكمه ستتولى هذا الملف
وتستمر فيه حتى ولو انه همم لغايه
هذا لا ينفي دور المحكمه واستمارها في ذلك
لان اذا اذا تاكد ان العداله الامريكيه
قد اخذت مجراها بطريق سليم طيب تاثير
السياسي هنا على اي تحقيقه دي يفتحوه
التحقيق الاغبياء يجب ننتظر
المحاكم الجنائيه الامريكيه الى امريكا لا
تعترفه الدوليه لكن حتى عدم هذه الاعتراف
لن ينكر او لم ياخذ الملف او
الهدايا الامريكيه لوحدها تستوي على هذا
الملف قبل
التاكد انه هناك محاكمه حقيقيه لهؤلاء
بانه
يعني ياخذوا من القضيه ولكن يخدم اسرائيل
بطريقه غير مباشره بطريقه مباشره
هناك يمكن من يطالب
الوقت
يتحرك اكثر الملف امام العداله الدوليه
لانه يجب معرفه القياده للمسؤوليه ليست
فقط مسؤوليه الجامعي
الوحده الوحده
مسؤوليه طيب سمعنا المؤتمر الصحفي الحديث
على ان اغتيال شيرين ابو عقله وهو يدخل في
اطار ومنهج
وطويله يعني منذ امد بعيد ضد الجزيره
لاسكاتي صوتها هذا العنصر ما الذي او كيف
سيكون حضوره في اطار قديم الجزيره اولا
تعرضت لتدمير امام العالم كله رغم انه لا
توجد ادله ان كان هناك ما يهدد اسرائيل
اذا الثار من الجزيره كان واضحا واستمر
والمضايقه للجزيره في عده مرات ومناسبات
بحيث اصبح هناك
استمراريه وديمومه نعم وعادات الجزيره
استهدافه الى درجه الى درجه عمليه قتل على
وتيره دائما
العالم العالم
نقدر معاك
لندن وافاق
والامال المعلقه على المحكمه الجنايات
الدوليه لمحاسبه المسؤولين ومتابعتهم
شكرا
ابو عاقله
وبالنسبه لان كان هناك امل هذا امر مهم
جدا من خلال مجتمعنا اليه من من عقد
المؤتمر الصحفي ان يكون هناك امل ولكن
علينا ان نركز على انه في شهر ابريل كان
هناك تقديم طلبات لصحفيين
ونسمعه ان هناك حاجه اليوم لمعالجه الوضع
المتعلق بصحفيه الجزيره بشكل خاص الذين
يقومون بالتغطيه في الاراضي المحتله وهذه
قضايا هي في خضم الولايه القضائيه للمحكمه
الجنائيه الدوليه لذلك انا اعمل ان يسير
قدما في هذا الامر لانه لم يكن هناك عمليه
تحقيق منطقيه او موثوق من الجانب
الاسرائيلي او الامريكيه ومما سمعناه
اليوم فهناك برهان على ان هناك حاجه
حقيقيه
للتركيز على ثقافه الفرار من العقوبه التي
تجري في اسرائيل والوقت لتحقيق هذا السير
في هذا المجال هو الان
اسرائيل رفضت التحقيق في الجريمه همم ولكن
حتى كما قال بعض الضيوف
كما يعني حتى لو فتحت التحقيق لا يكون
هناك يعني اذانا او همم نتائج الان
الادله او همم ملف الادله كامل امام
المدعي العام هناك همم شهادات وهناك ااه
شهوده طبعا وهناك همم
تسجيلات بصوت والصوره لما اجرى هل هذا
كافر
لادانه سواء الذين نفذوا او الذين اعطوا
الاوامر
هذا السؤال لا يمكنني الاجابه عنه لانه
ليس لديه سبيل للوصول الى المواد التي هي
في حوزه المدعي العام للمحكمه الجنائي
الدوليه
هذا امر يمكن ان نتحدث عنه في قطر
ولديه المواد اللازمه فيما يتعلق به الوضع
في اوكرانيا ايضا ونعمل ان يقوم بالتحقيق
فيما يجري
مختلفا اصلا عن التحقيق فيما يجري في
اسرائيل
في المؤتمر الصحفي او احدهم كان يتحدث من
القاعه اشار الى انه على مدى اكثر من عام
منذ
مسؤوليته لم يكن هناك تحرك حقيقي في الملف
اذا المشكله هنا اوسع من مجرد مشكله
التحقيق في جريمه قتل شيرين ابو عاقله
ولكن هناك عدم حماس واضح لدى المدعي العام
للسير في هذه القضيه المتعلقه بفلسطين
وهذا يعتبر جوهر المشكله حاليا
امامه الان ملف متكامل من من الادله
وشهادات شهود عيان وايضا همم
مقامت به الجزيره ومؤسسات اخرى من تحقيقات
اثبتت ان الاستهلاف كان متعمدا وفي سياق
عام وهو استهلاف شبكه الجزيره واسكاتها هل
هذا الامر سيكون همم لربما مساله هذه
الملف ومساله استهلاف الجزيره قد يقوي
موقف همم هيئه الدفاع او الفريق القانوني
اشاره
انا في نفس الموقف لذلك ليس لدي ادله لكي
اعلق ولكن يمكنني
مختصر
للمحكمه الجنائيه الدوليه ما لم يكن هناك
قضيه مفحمه ومقنعه
ودمغه انا بالنسبه لي همم اقول ان هناك
ادله الجنائيه وشرعيه قامت بتحديد مسار
الرصاصه وهذا يشير الى مكان انطلاقها
المساله هي كيفيه اثبات ان كان هذا العمل
متعمدا ام لا مره اخرى هذا يتعلق بالادله
التي بحوزته
والشهود
فيدان
الاسرائيليون والامريكيون لم يقوموا
بالتحقيق مع اي شاهد اذا فان قالوا هذه
ليست همم
ادله كافيه امر اجده غير منطقي الامر يعود
الى المده الى العام لكي يقر ان كان هناك
ادله كافيه
العمليه قدما لان المحكمه الجنائي الدوليه
لديها الولايه القضائيه للتحقيق في
الاراضي المحتله وايضا في حالات اخرى
متعلقه باستهدافه مبنى الجزيره هذا العام
اذا هناك عدد من القضايا يجب النظر فيها
وان يتم التحقيق فيها وهذا يضيف الى وزن
وثقل الادله التي سوف تقوده حسب ما نامل
الى عمليه تحقيق كامله
ما هي الخطوه الاولى التي تتوقع ان تقوم
بها محكمه او المدعي ان يقوم بها المدعي
العام في المحكمه الجنائيه الدوليه
هذا العام
تغلب على كل العقبات القانونيه وهناك
اجراءات
المحكمه وتم معالجتها
يمكن ان يكون اصلا قد قام بعمليه التحقيق
وليس عليه التزام بان يرفع تقريرا الى
الشخص او من هم معلومه في القضيه الى ان
يحينا الوقت بحيث تصبح هذه القضيه عامه
ويكون هناك امر بالاعتقال اذا ليس هناك
الان دليل على انه همم
اه اعتذر
انه وعد بالذهاب الى الاراضي المحتله في
العام الجديد اذا فنحن بالتالي بحاجه الى
اظهار وبرهان منهم بانه مهتم جدا في
ملاحقته هؤلاء الاشخاص والسعي في هذه
القضيه وهذا يتطلب نشاطات وفعاليات وقضايا
مثل
استجواب الشهود وايضا الفريق القانوني
للعائله لابد انه على علم بهذا ان كان هذا
اصلا قد بدا ام لا اذا واضح ان المدعي
العام لم يقم باتخاذ الخطوات الضروريه الى
الان اذا الرغبه الان هي ان يكون هناك
بادره حقيقيه بان المدعي العام يقوم بذلك
فعلا وعليه ان اضيف رغم ان المددع العام
لديه همم تصرفات حقيقيه الا انه
ما عليه بعدد من الموا الكافيه منذ بدايه
الصراع المسلح في اوكرانيا الكثير من
الحكومات الغربيه همم قدموا لهم مساعده
ماليه
وايضا قدموا له الاشخاص الخضراء ليساعدوه
اذا فهذا لا يجب ان يكون منحصرا في قضيه
اخرى
لذلك هو لديه موارد تمد انعام يمكن ان
تدخل في التحقيق في القضيه في فلسطين ويجب
ان يقوم بذلك ولكن مره اخرى شكرا
من المدعي العام ان يقوم بهذه العمليه
ولكن الى الان ليس لدينا الدليل الكاذب
انه يقوم بذلك
في القانون الدولي والرئيس السابق لنجاه
الامم المتحده لحقوق الانسان كما اشكره
ضيفنا ايضا من لندن المحامي المختص همم
المختص في القانون الدولي وحقوق الانسان